I am Ivan Budassi, I am the director
arba arba executive is the agency of
collection of the province of good
airs
the drone and the satellite images we
allows you to be more efficient on a flight
of half an hour we can draw thousands of
quick photographs simple and efficient
the Buenos Aires province- encompasses what
would be the surface of france
Spain 'or Italy is a country within
a country with the area that has the
province of buenos aires we can
send our inspectors to
check each of the homes or each
one of the fields
for our inspectors really
it is very violent that people who have
the highest purchasing power in the country
does not comply with their positions is not going to
change the equation at all
economic the families that come here
in complying with taxes
our obligation is to follow them and
chase him and tell this glass that if
He does not come, we're going to go
search and we will find it
conversation